i i wonder if we can start with with
with the book perhaps
uh men who hate women it is a title that
i'm sure we'll put a few noses out of
joint and
provoke a few hashtag not all men
responses but tell us just a little bit
about what
what what his central argument is
well the clue's in the title it's men
who hate women not
men hate women we know that the vast
majority of men out there would never
dream and believe in behaving in these
ways
but nonetheless it is important to
recognize that there is a real
undercurrent of extremist misogyny in
this country and around the world
and what the book uncovers is that there
are communities of men
actively advocating that women should be
raped should be brutally murdered should
be kept as sex slaves
and that these men are in communities
hundreds of thousands strong they're not
just a few weirdos on the internet as
people might like to think
what's really worrying is that the
research for the book uncovered the fact
that they're very deliberately
radicalizing and grooming young men in
ways that we simply don't necessarily
recognize
so many teenage boys are being very
deliberately reached out to by these
communities and given these real
misconceptions about feminism and about
women
and that they're leaking out further
into our society as well
you know 27 of american men now say that
they wouldn't have a meeting one-to-one
in the workplace on their own with a
woman
some of these ideas that we might think
of as very niche and extreme online
issues are actually becoming
quite worryingly widespread just in
terms of these
these misogynist networks hundreds of
thousands of people being indoctrinated
in essence you know who are responsible
for them
who are behind them i mean you mentioned
that it's not just about some some
weirdos in the internet because
your thoughts immediately go to the
in-cell movement but it's it's a lot
bigger than that clearly
it is it does include the in-cell
movement so-called involuntary celibate
men who believe that they're not having
sex and blame women for not giving it to
them
but it also goes much further than that
it includes groups like men's rights
activists
uh so-called pickup artists that's a
hundred million dollar global
industry essentially training men to
sexually harass and in some cases
sexually assault women
some of these are industry so-called
leaders who can rake in thousands of
pounds from their supporters from
running boot camps
so there is money there and there's also
a political benefit to be had from
courting these groups
one cambridge analytica whistleblower
for example said that steve bannon had
deliberately courted the in-cell vote
for donald trump
so these are much bigger and perhaps
much more powerful groups groups than we
might have acknowledged previously
so so how best then for us to intervene
in these networks in these spaces and
and in fact who best
to intervene in these networks because
it strikes me that that in these
communities a woman's voice is probably
not desperately welcomed
yes i think we do need to see men
stepping up and offering young people in
particular alternative places to get
that sense of
community and of purpose and of role
modeling masculinity that these
communities are so seductively providing
we also need to support vulnerable
teenage boys who are very seduced by
these communities
in part because of massive funding cuts
to offline places where they could have
got those kinds of input so for example
youth centers
adolescent mental health funding we need
to protect and support young men so that
they don't fall prey to what really is a
radicalizing and grooming network
although we never label it in that way
in just the same way that we don't label
the many men who have come
offline and acted carried out massacres
of women
in the name of exactly some of these
movements terrorists we don't use the
word terrorism to describe them
we don't call what they're doing online
radicalization and yet i think we can
see in our society all around us the
impact of this extremist misogyny being
very deliberately spread
this week perhaps you know as much as
ever lord given given
this the scale of the problem which some
people seem to become aware of only in
the past kind of couple of weeks you
know that
practically every woman has experienced
some form of abuse perhaps even sexual
assault or
you know and given the fact that you
know
that a lot of men have been you know
ultimately responsible for it i mean how
confident are you that there is actually
a way out of this
i think that there is a way forward but
what it needs is real systemic
structural change and not just
platitudes
you know a lot of people have said this
week wow this is a tipping point this is
a moment of reckoning
as if women have never before risen up
in a cry of grief and rage and shared
their millions of stories
this carries on happening and it will
continue to happen unless we start to
take notice of all of these cases not
just the odd one that hits
the headline you know this book would
have been relevant a couple of months
ago when an older woman
was was killed by her husband who
strangled her to death and was given
just five years in prison it would have
been relevant less than a year ago when
police officers were taking selfies of
themselves next to the
murdered bodies of two black women it
would have been relevant on any one of
the
um two women a week who are killed on
average in the uk
um every week so you know this is an
ongoing problem but if we want to see
that change happen it is possible
but what it takes is political and
structural will so it takes education
looking at what we're teaching boys at
school instead of telling girls not to
wear short skirts
and it needs somebody to have the will
to take on the institutional reform
that's needed of a justice system
that is systematically institutionally
racist and misogynistic
just 1.5 percent of rape cases reported
to the police
in this country result in a charge or
summons so that's where we need to be
looking for structural
change not telling women to stay in at
night or to wear something different
well laura let's let's see if if any or
most of that takes place at some point
soon i certainly hope so a lot of bass
good to have you on the program this
morning thank you so much for joining us